My name's Ben Halperin.
I'm originally from New Jersey.
Been living in Columbus, Ohio for
the last two and a half years now.
When I was learning through Udacity,
I was working full time
as a mechanical engineer.
At that point I was looking for
a way to change careers.
I ended up taking
the Front-End Web Developer Nanodegree.
Probably the biggest doubt I had
during the whole experience was,
will I be able to get a job?
I graduated from
the Nanodegree late December.
After that, I took maybe a week or
two to update my resume, portfolio,
LinkedIn, everything like that.
Started applying to jobs.
I wanted to move back to either New York
or Boston and be closer to my family.
I started getting responses back, had
some interviews, basically went through
their whole process, the same process
anyone else would go through.
Ended up getting an on-site interview.
Went through that, went really well.
I really liked the people I met, and
then I heard back the next
week that I got the job.
But I think the portfolio of projects is
really what got my resume to stand out
among the other ones,
considering I didn't have a CS degree or
any work experience as
a software developer.
I think the problems they gave me during
the technical interview, I wouldn't have
been able to solve if I hadn't
taken the courses through Udacity,
if I hadn't gone through the nanodegree.
I guess Udacity's way of teaching,
I think,
just gives you a really good basis for
learning something else or tackling
a problem you haven't seen before.
I think it definitely
helped me get the job.
[MUSIC]